what is going on everybody welcome to
part three of the robotics with the
Raspberry Pi in the go p-- aegyo
tutorial series in this video we're
actually to begin programming our go PI
go so at this point your go pi go should
be fully set up and ready to go so that
means that you've got power going to it
you're able to login via SSH and
possibly with some sort of file transfer
GUI up if you're on Windows I prefer
winscp but if you're on say Mac you
might be using FileZilla or something
like that just as a little bit of a tip
one thing you can do is go to options
preferences editors and you can choose
the type of editor you want to use
depending on the extension so for me I
set up an extension for dot py to be
idle and that path to that is this you
can either use the Python 3.4 or 2.7 it
looks to me that most of the go PI go
kind of framework is written in Python 2
so that's what we're going to be using
but you could try to convert it to
Python 3 if you so chose but we'll skip
that
so anyways we'll close that out and
we're going to go ahead and close this
out just wanted to show you that you can
do that at least here but you can do the
same thing on FileZilla so pay attention
to that now the first thing that we're
going to go ahead and do is we're going
to make a new directory we're going to
go into desktop and make a directory
here you can either do that in your SCP
like file new directory or on your
actual Raspberry Pi you can do LS and
that'll give you the contents of the
current directory we're going to go
ahead and change directory into desktop
so CD desktop easy enough now we're
going to go sudo actually let's try it
let's see if we get a little make door
and then go PI go local good now I can
list out there's go PI go local so now
we'll CD in to go PI go local and there
shouldn't really be anything there but
if i refresh desktop there's my go PI go
local this is where we're going to put
all of our scripts that we're going to
write
here now the next thing that we're going
to go ahead and do is just kind of peek
at the go p-- aegyo framework so what
I'm going to go ahead and do here is
let's go file new actually we'll come
back to that and suck
so now let's navigate back to just home
PI ok and we're going to look into the
go p-- aegyo directory here now this
will be here if you installed go PI go
via their their image or if you have
their SD card and so on so we're going
to go ahead and go PI go now this might
be somewhere else if you installed viola
like there github and stuff like that so
so depending on where you put go PI go
this might actually be somewhere else
another way that you can get there is
going to be via going to the actual
package location so if I if I run Python
real quick and I go import go PI go
because I've installed go PI go oops oh
shoot : let's quit out of this pseudo
Python and then import go PI go then
what we can do is you can print go PI go
dot on your score underscore file
underscore underscore and then I'll give
you the full location of go PI go so you
could go in there and find the go pi go
stuff too but anyway within here I can
go here software and then Python and
then we can actually view the go p-- I
go to PI so double click on that and
that will bring up the the actual the
main kind of framework file that we've
got going on just make the text a little
bigger so in here you can kind of ignore
all this and you can come down to
basically here so this will let you
control motor 1 motor to this so this
command would let you go forward
backward for a specific motor and then
backward for the entire go PI go turn
left rotate left but basically like a
pivot here go right rotate right stop
increase speed decrease speed you can do
some trimming digital read
really as for the Arduino so we're not
doing anything there scrolling on down
trying to find there some more stuff
this is for your distance sensor you can
just invoke this so we'll be doing that
you can turn on the LED lights you can
turn them off you can control the servo
and position it and so on there's a
bunch of stuff that you can do here so
anyway I at some point you should go
through this look at all the functions
that are available to you but we're
going to run through a bunch of them
right now so there's that now I'm going
to head back into home PI go into
desktop go PI go local right click new
file and I'm just going to call this
tutorial 3 dot pi hit ok that creates it
and it pops up a new window for me and
then everything I write here and save
it's going to go directly into there so
to start we're going to go ahead and
we're going to start writing a quick
script that's going to allow us to
interact with our PI now the script that
I'm going to write here um well first
let's go ahead let's just do import go
PI go actually let's do wrong go PI go
import asterisk and asterisk is going to
basically give us all of the functions
then what we can do is something as
simple as this we could say forward and
then let's go ahead and also let's
import time and then forward time dot
time or time asleep - and then bwd for
backward time dot sleep - and then we'll
do stop and that'll stop the actual
raspberry or the go PI goes so we can
save that and you probably if that's the
first time you logged in you might have
to reenter your password but I'm I'm all
set there so now I've got tutorial 3
here and we could run it here but before
we do that actually first let me quit
out of Python
before we do that I want to just talk
real briefly you should see the
Raspberry Pi in the frame here Oh what's
going on there is I've got it kind of
set up on a little bin that basically
keeps the wheels off the ground so this
allows me to control the Raspberry Pi
move it forward backwards rotate all
that but the wheels aren't on the ground
so the PI and the Gope I go itself is
not going anywhere so I highly recommend
you figure out some sort of setup like
that where you can kind of put the go PI
go
resting on top of something so the
wheels can spin freely
this way you can develop without your go
PI go like running into walls or you
keep having like get up and bring it
back to a starting point it's good to
just kind of keep it suspended a little
bit so now we're ready to do is we're
going to come back over to our shell
here for SSH and we're gonna go sudo
whoops mine there yeah yeah sudo python
tutorial three dot pi and I'll go ahead
and run that now and you should see it
moves forward and then backward and then
it stopped so you should have seen the
wheels spinning in that example now you
might have noticed the wheels spun
pretty slow this is because I'm actually
I'm powering the entire go p-- I go via
the micro USB connection so one thing to
note is if you're pairing your go PI go
via say the the cord that they gave you
if you got like the full kit that is a
one amp power so it's only enough really
to power the PI you're not going to be
able to power both motors so what I
actually have here this is a 2.1 amp
power plug you know for like a cell
phone or something like that
plugging that in i'm able to control
actually everything I've got the camera
that works the distance sensor works the
motors both motors work they both spin
everything works with 2.1 amps so that's
pretty nice I do have the battery pack
on the back and obviously to run the
Gope I go all on its own you'll want to
disconnect the you know microUSB power
now as you can see that's pretty simple
right you can just start entering these
commands go forwards backwards stop and
all that and you're already able to
control this robot with you know very
few lines of code the sleeps aren't
really that you know required it was
just to keep things spinning for a
certain amount of time but as you can
see this is really easy to start
controlling the robot so the next steps
that we're going to do is to create some
sort of system where we can really
easily control this robot with our
keyboard and then from there we'll kind
of move into autonomy and stuff like
that but for now in the next tutorial
we'll actually control this with key
presses rather than hard coding the
controls into there if you had any
problems leading up to this point please
feel free to leave your questions
comments concerns whatever below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video